.
>> THANKS, DAVID.
AND WE WILL KEEP YOU UPDATED ON
THAT STORY.
INTENT TO MORE FOLLOW-UP FOR THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
AFTER SAYING HE HAS TOTAL
CONFIDENCE ON GENERAL MARK
MILLEY.
HE REMEMBERED THAT NEW BOOK
WHERE HE CALLED CHINA TO
UNDERMINE TRUMP?
NO ONE IS DENYING THAT THE CALLS
TOOK PLACE.
THE KEY NOW IS TO FIND A BOOK
WAS AND REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS ARE
DEMANDING ANSWERS.
>> ADD THE VIDEO DIFFICULT HAVE
TO CALL WITH THE CHINESE THAT
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT.
FOR YOU NOT TO TELL THE
PRESIDENT THAT YOU HAD TO CALL
WITH THE CHINESE AND FROM HIM
NOT TO BE A WORK AT THAT IS THE
PROBLEM.
IT IS BECAUSE YOU WANT HIM TO BE
ALL INFORMED AND AT HIS BEST TO
PROCEED.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE BACK OF THE
CHINESE.
YOU HAVE THE BACK OF YOUR
PRESIDENT.
>> IF, IN FACT, THAT IS TRUE,
THOSE WOULD BE COUNTS OF
INSUBORDINATION AND DOUG
APPROPRIATE ACTION WOULD BE
COURT-MARTIALED PROCEDURAL.
>> SAID, IF WE ARE GOING TO DO
SOMETHING, WE ARE GOING TO GIVE
YOU A HEADS UP?
THAT IS SO UNCONSTITUTIONAL, SO
WRONG.
>> JOHN KENNEDY SUGGESTING BIDEN
MAY SCAPEGOAT MILLIE TO DISTRACT
FROM HIS AFGHANISTAN FAILURE.
>> I KNOW PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS
SAID HE STANDS BEHIND GENERAL
MILLEY.
AND MAYBE THAT IS TRUE IN THE
SHORT TEMPERED I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU EVEN ODDS THAT EVENTUALLY
THE WHITE HOUSE THROWS HIM UNDER
THE BUS.
BECAUSE THE WHITE HOUSE
DESPERATELY NEEDS SOMEONE
BESIDES THE PRESIDENT ON WHICH
TO BLAME.
A THE STANDING INCOMPETENCE IN
AFGHANISTAN.
>> LET'S HEAR PREDICTION.
DOES MILLIE STATE ON THIS OR
DOES HE GET CANNED?
>> I DON'T HAVE THE SLIGHTEST
IDEA.
BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU IS THIS.
IF THINGS, REALLY BAD IF THE
CORONAVIRUS, IF THEY CAN'T GET
MORE PEOPLE VACCINATED, THE
ECONOMY IS GOING TO -- CAN I SEE
IT?
AND AFGHANISTAN IS A MESS.
LEAVING AMERICANS BEHIND.
INFLATION IS A MESS.
I MEAN, SOMEBODY HAS TO THERE.
IF ANYONE DOES, HE GOES.
THAT I WOULD NOT BE SORRY TO
HEAR HIM GOING BECAUSE
APPARENTLY THERE'S ONLY TWO
PEOPLE WHO CAN GIVE HIM
PERMISSION TO CALL HIS CHINESE
COUNTERPART, ASSUMING THAT HE
SAID WHAT WOODWARD IS A SAYING
HE SAID AND THAT IS THE
PRESIDENT OR THE ACTING
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE WHICH WAS
THIS GUY, MILLER.
AND THEY SAID, WE DID NOT GIVE
HIM PERMISSION TO DO THAT BUT IT
IS ABOUT CIVILIAN CONTROL BUT I
DON'T LIKE HIM RESPONDING TO
NANCY PELOSI'S CALLS.
HE GETS HIS WIFE IN IN A TIZZY
AND HE DECIDES HE IS GOING TO
WIN TO EVERYONE IN NUCLEAR
WEAPONS ISSUE AND HE IS GOING TO
TELL THEM TO COME TO ME FIRST?
SINCE WHEN DO THEY COME TO YOU
FIRST?
YOU GO TO THE PRESENT FIRST.
>> NANCY PELOSI IS NOT THE CHAIN
OF COMMAND.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT.
>> THAT IS THE TOPIC.
>> THE TOPIC IS WHETHER OR NOT
--
>> I KNOW.
THAT IS THE PART OF THE STORY.
SPEAK TO RICHARD.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
>> BUT I THINK WE SHOULD WORK ON
GETTING ALL THE FACTS BEFORE WE
JUMP TO CONCLUSIONS.
NUMBER ONE --
>> WHY WOULD WE DO THAT?
>> BECAUSE WE ARE THE NEWS.
BUT NUMBER ONE, ANY TIME A BOOK
IS RELEASING A BOOK, WHAT THEY
DO IS THEY FIND THE MOST
SALACIOUS LINES OF THE BOOK AND
THE POLICE TO APPS OF PEOPLE
LIKE US CAN CHEW OVER THEM AND
BECAUSE OUR POLITICS HAVE BECOME
SO ABSOLUTISM, PEOPLE LIKE THE
POLITICIANS THAT WE SAW THAT
THERE UP MOST OF THEM WILL
LIKELY BE --
>> MILLIE -- HE DID NOT DENY IT.
>> HE IS DOING HIS JOB.
HE IS NOT GOING TO GET IN THAT
LEADS ON THIS.
SO WHAT YOU HAVE IS -- EXPECTED
TO ADVISE THE PRESIDENT.
>> WHAT YOU HAVE HERE IS A LINE
RELEASED FROM THE BOOK THAT WAS
CLEARLY SENSATIONALIZED AND YOU
HAVE ACTUAL JOURNALISTS
SUPPORTING IT LIKE OUR VERY OWN
JENNIFER GRIFFIN.
THIS CALL DID NOT HAPPEN IN
SECRET.
THE FIRST CALL THAT HAPPENED
WITH THE CHINESE GENERAL AND
WITH MILLEY INVOLVED WAS A CALL
THAT WAS INITIATED BY THE
DEFENSE SECRETARY EXPERT.
BEFORE WE GET INTO THIS, AND WE
ALSO HAD EVERY OLD JACK KANE WHO
TALKED ABOUT THIS AND SAID,
BEFORE WE JUMPED AT THIS CAN ALL
OF THE FACTS AND LET'S NOT CALL
FOR TRANSCRIPTS ARE BECAUSE MANY
TIMES, WHEN THESE CALLS HAPPEN,
THEY HAVE BEEN IN SECRET BECAUSE
THEY COULD BE TALKING ABOUT A
LOT OF THINGS.
AND WE DESTROYED BACK CHANNELS
THAT WE HAVE BETWEEN US AND
OTHER FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS.
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS THAT WE HAVE
THAT RELATIONSHIPS WITH BECAUSE
WE WANT TO BE ABLE --
>> THE RICK -- UKRAINE PHONE
CALLS.
THAT IS THE PENTAGON'S OPINION.
DANA DO YOU THINK WOODWARD AND
COSTA REPORTED THIS?
THAT MAYBE THEY GOT A LEAK OF
THE TRANSCRIPTS?
DO YOU THINK SOMEONE TOLD THEM
WHO WAS ON THE CALL EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED?
IT IS NOT LIKE THEY WOULD MAKE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS UP.
>> OKAY.
WELL, ALL RIGHT WELL, I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE'S A TRANSCRIPT.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW, IF THERE ARE
TRANSCRIPT.
OR AT LEAST THERE MIGHT BE
TRANSCRIPTS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT WORKS.
I WOULD DOUBT THAT THE GOT A
TRANSCRIPT.
I WOULD IMAGINE, THIS IS A
DESCRIPTION OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN GENERAL.
THE ACCUSATION IS QUITE GENERAL.
COULD WE GET THE FACTS TO FIND
OUT WHAT WAS SAID AND WHAT WAS
THE CHAIN OF COMMAND?
DID THE DEPUTY NOTE?
IS THAT GOOD ENOUGH?
I DON'T KNOW.
HE WOULD HAVE TO ANSWER THAT IS
WILL.
I WONDER ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
COSTA AND WOODWARD ARE NOT JUST
ANY OLD AUTHORS.
NOTHING IN THE BOOKS THAT WE
WRITE EXACTLY -- ACTUALLY
BREAKING NEWS.
THESE TWO ARE -- BOOK
ESPECIALLY, COSTA.
HE IS A REPORTER FOR THE
WASHINGTON POST.
GENERAL MILLEY IS THE -- IN THE
OFFICE OF THE JOINT CHIEFS.
HE HAS BEEN ADVISING THE
PRESIDENT AS WE SPEAK.
SO IF THIS GUY IS USURPING THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF, THAT IS BIG
NEWS.
AND THAT SHOULD NOT BE HELD TO
HAVE A ONE LINE LEAK TO SELL A
BUNCH OF BOOKS TO FIND OUT NEXT
WEEK THAT ACTUALLY WAS ALL WANTS
AND CONTEXT DOES NOT ALLOW US TO
TREMENDOUS GUY'S LIFE?
SO I'M SKEPTICAL ABOUT IT.
I'M NOT SAYING IT DID NOT
HAPPEN.
I JUST DON'T KNOW.
AND I'M CURIOUS ABOUT HOW
COMFORTABLE THE AUTHORS ARE THAT
THIS IS HAPPENING.
>> AND IF YOU ARE JOE BIDEN, YOU
CAN'T TRUST THIS GUY.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF HE KNOWS WHAT
IS GOING ON.
I DO ENJOY THE COGNITIVE
DISSONANCE AND PEOPLE WHO CAN
EASILY REVERSE THIS.
SAY THE GENERAL IS GOING AROUND
JOE BIDEN.
>> BECAUSE HE BELIEVES THAT THAT
MENTAL DECLINE HAS BECOME SO
SERIOUS THAT WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING.
THE PEOPLE THAT WOULD BE
DEFENDING MILLEY WOULD BE
CONDEMNING MILLEY.
YOU HAVE TO STEP BACK AND DO
KIND OF A COMPARISON.
WE HAVE -- THE PHONE CALLS.
WE ALREADY HAD TWO PHONE CALLS
UNDER JOE BIDEN.
THE GOD THE CALLS WITH THE
AFGHAN PRESIDENT TO INSTRUCT HIM
TO LIVE.
DO WE KNOW WHAT WAS ON BEHALF OF
OUR COUNTRY?
OR WAS IT ON THE BEHALF OF
SOMETHING ELSE?
>> NOT PERFECT PHONE CALLS.
>> MILLEY IS A SYMPTOM OF THE
EMOTIONAL SPASM THAT WENT ON
FROM 2016 TO 2020.
IT WAS NOT THE AMERICANS.
IT WAS THE MEDIA, THE PEOPLE IN
POWER, THAT CAUSED THEM TO
OVERLOOK A VIRUS THAT WAS
SPREADING OUT OF CHINA.
A CONCERTED EFFORT TO DISQUALIFY
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ALL BECAUSE THEY HATED THIS GUY
WHO HAD BEEN TWEETS AND MADE
MEAN JOKES WHO IS AN OUTSIDER
CALLING BS ON ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE.
RIGHT?
THIS IS ABOUT GETTING RID OF THE
MOST DANGEROUS PRESIDENT IN
WORLD HISTORY, THE ONE WHO
REMOVED THE THREAT OF NORTH
KOREA FROM THE TABLE, USHERED IN
PEACE FROM THE MIDDLE EAST, WHO
HELPED OPERATION WARP SPEED
BEGIN AND DID NOT TAKE A
PAYCHECK PICKUP TRUCK AND YET --
PAYCHECK.
AND YET ADULTS LIKE MILLEY HAVE
ALLUDED THOSE DELUDED THEMSELVES
INTO -- IT IS ABOUT THAT --
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW THAT?
>> IT IS PART OF THE STORY.
CHINA CALLED AND SA